first of all thank you guys so much I
want to thank the amazingly handsome
Barney okay all right let's do some QA
you get it stuck I see feet in the mud
you have been caught in the flood while
the water is imparted we run we put you
soda harvesters us you have been
enjoying your life sipping the syrup and
aligned in no way taking whatever you
touch disorder the wicked is covered in
blood there's got a question good yep
yep what's your name what's your name is
that's what's their mindsets broken at
the most high I don't know you let me
rephrase probably I mean look how many
people here have been positively
affected by my content so so you know
like right like like there's something I
don't know exactly what it is to me to
me my big thing is I don't want you know
I'm thrilled that I've motivated you to
do something but I think I've motivated
people to do something out of
practicality and truth I'm not here to
coddle you I'm here to tell you the
truth and actually how many people here
when they first came across me actually
didn't like me raise your hand and the
reason that is is because I'm going so
hard at the truth that if you're not in
the right place you're mad at me because
I'm calling out on your [ __ ] and that's
uncomfortable I feel that you know like
it's just the way it is so probably but
it's very deeply grounded in psychology
you know and and you have to be you have
to have those skill sets and that app to
get there die man
yes
yes that's good I'm hungry too let's
start with this and I'm glad you
actually asked this question I think the
biggest thing that I just took away from
all this
besides all the ridiculously warm
feelings is my concern
/ curiosity if you really know what your
finish line is or at least a finish line
not maybe your ultimate finish line but
a let's start with you let's use it this
is for everybody okay you want to start
a brand around that food culture right
yeah if I told you I'm a weird [ __ ]
genie from the future
and I can make it the first great thing
happen what's the first great day yes
and so you want to make that successful
and live off of it and that's your life
right you make whether you make five
hundred thousand a year
thirty nine thousand a year for you
obviously got to pay for your lifestyle
but what do you think the minimum amount
of money you want to make for your life
like like like what would be the minimum
amount of money that you make every year
that allowed you to live and do that
content Mediasite what do you think
great so you're like what is amazing
about that if that's where you're at
well then at this young of an age and
that's where you're at and the fact that
you're even here and you know it's just
unbelievable amounts of content in
written audio and visual form on
Instagram snapchat Facebook Twitter and
YouTube and podcast and I will tell you
I would be flabbergasted in three four
five six years unless you suck which you
may but if you don't suck and you have
that little of a financial need right
which is remarkable which is the biggest
thing something here I don't know if
they're here said you made me realize I
didn't need Rolexes and things of that
nature right like the biggest reason so
many of you will fail is your number for
success is far greater than his you
think you need a million which will then
mean that you're gonna do a lot of
things when you don't get a million very
quickly that won't ever get you a
million so if you if you think what I
just said is cool which is bleed for six
years in a row
you'll probably get sponsorship or sales
of product to 40,000 a year to me that's
what I did I knew what I wanted I was
willing to give up my 20s for it gave
him up gave him up you know somebody
said it's difficult not to document
right now I'm like but I but I didn't
write but like what should I build my
business or should I document I'm like
both he's like well I got to pick one
I'm like build your business like so if
you're if your ambitions are that humble
which they are that's incredible that
excites me because by the way here's the
funny part that's who I was too I just
needed a hundred thousand a year just
that seemed rich to me right like I was
like cool um I'll be okay like like I'll
have a house like you know it's not you
know I just needed to play much I needed
the game and too many people too many of
you in here want the stuff not the game
when you fall in love with the game
everything's different because you've
already won that's real it sounds cliche
but it's real
myself but since I work for a pest
control company well you know Davies
right there he's right there you can
start pitching him uh so I'm obsessed
with blood did I mean we have an office
here right there's a lot of places I can
have an office right like specially for
creative shop like Amsterdam there's a
lot of places I could have chose um I'm
a huge fan of London I'm a huge fan of
this country I'm a huge fan of London
I'm just a big fan man like I you know
the food's okay but you know because I
grew up in the wine business so it you
know I know there's a bunch of tallian
dude so like Italy France right like I
was spoiled in my 20s Europe mint wine
country which meant great food countries
France Italy France Italy Spain France
Italy Germany so like so it was funny
I'd never been to London until I was
like 32 years old right and I was like
oh [ __ ] the food sucks you know like but
but but you know as an American you know
who was born in Eastern Europe there's a
lot of romance I have towards London
because it's just further ahead but it
also shows me all the vulnerabilities
that America has over the next hundred
two hundred years I think the biggest
problem in general with Western Europe
is the Alpha side of me
doesn't respect the way the game is
played so I don't like having an office
in London because if that good-looking
man right next to you sucks I can't
really follow it fire him and I think
that's stupid you know like the laws of
doing business in Europe are such
[ __ ] and it's they're soft and
that's why China and Asia and America
will always beat Europe in the game
where I cold called
a beer company that I see right yeah I
mean it was like I called some company
which like I was trying to teach people
you can sell at any point I went to
Google cuz there's no social really yet
and there was a company that was
advertising beer and I called them put
on speaker and told him I'm starting a
beer blog I have a wine blog I wasn't
going to but I was trying to teach
everybody and the guy was down for the
conversation what I think you need to be
careful of is I think where people get
caught is they over promise and under
deliver it's too early if you're gonna
tell some company that if they give you
a thousand it's gonna be good for their
business it's gonna be good for you you
[ __ ] know the answer you're just
trying to make some more content which I
respect
yeah right getting [ __ ] on today that
sounds awesome yeah I like it I like it
I like it I'll tell you why cuz I even I
can tell by your demeanor that you're
gonna be okay
the fact that you realize that that
negative moment has positive impact the
question is why did it happen and that's
what you have to be honest with yourself
I don't know you know but that's you
know I'm pumped that you can have the I
mean you're more positive and half the
people here and it sounds like you're
having a terrible day
that's why I wanted to ask you how do
you keep the positivity the calmness
because basically when things happen I
go the other way so tonight I just was
reminding myself every time I in every
time you came and next person came I'm
just reminding my little e in my own
head saying you don't mean [ __ ] I said
to one of you I said they said how do
you stay humble when you're so
successful I'm like because I know if I
die tomorrow I'll have a good day on
social media like most comments ever on
my latest post on Instagram and
everybody to be like oh [ __ ] that was
the last one weird and and I know that
all of you will be on with your life
a week later you have to balance your
ego with humility in the same way when
I'm having my worst day I realize I'm
the best I'm gonna be the best that ever
does this and so the way I handle things
is when something's going one way I use
all my emotional strength to push the
other way what are you gonna cry for us
your life cuz the conference got [ __ ]
up like I just like to me it's just like
look what the [ __ ] going guys
if you're in this room right now let me
just remind you that there are seven
point seven billion people literally
right now as we stand here there are
women being shipped to be strippers in
parts of our world right now as we stand
here there are women who are basically
caged mentally usually and are being
shipped to dance on a pole in Manhattan
and in London like do you understand
what's good there's there's genocide
going on right now like what do you
think's going on like we lack
perspective your conference got [ __ ]
up boohoo I lost a client boohoo
there's people [ __ ] dying out there
like like so when Americans or Europeans
talk to me about race or gender I'm sad
it's the real life but I remind them
because it's a positive thing cool but
let me tell you about the person that's
ranked seven billion in the world they
[ __ ] have it bad and so I just I
struggle like I want to write like I
listen I'm weird I think about things
like animals like I don't know
like if you're the best elephant we are
still better than you like you know like
without really listen you know I got hot
on this about a year ago the four
hundred trillion to one it's impossible
to be a human being
you won I don't know how to get upset
after that I keep [ __ ] in perspective
right like you're gonna learn from this
you [ __ ] up
I promise you it's failing cuz you and
and when you start owning your [ __ ] and
not blaming other people and I think
this is the kick I've been on lately on
Instagram right like play yourself uh
you know what I'm always happy I play
myself when you blame yourself for real
you're gonna always be happy because you
don't feel like somebody else controls
you you know and listen think about all
the [ __ ] I've said on Instagram you see
it you've been into my [ __ ] for three
months you see it and you're like what
the [ __ ] does he mean right like like
like like it's it's about eliminating
being at the mercy of anything or anyone
right it's mentleman mentalism right
it's like just being like real base I'm
basic as [ __ ] up here it's fine there
you know I mean it I mean it I'm real
basic good bad good bad black white on
me on me on me my fault there's nothing
you can say the venue [ __ ] you you
picked the venue your fault your fault
your fault
no you know why your fault because you
[ __ ] cut a corner the only time you
get scammed is when you cut corners
underpriced attention my religion my
religion
years old how do you go about finding
that on the press attention and how do
you know price too many of you in here
have ego around your time when it's the
only thing you got so the reason I
always know is cuz I work because I work
I work I try things I test IDM you back
i suite I work so when you're in [ __ ]
you taste it and when you've done it for
20 years
you see patterns Facebook's still
underpriced you just can't target 22 to
25 year old african-american fans of
football because other people are doing
that too now it's just like Google early
on you could just target soccer one-word
five cents a click I did it
wine wine wine but then I had to put at
the end of the game now I got to put
2013 you know Heller cellars Zinfandel
like long tail real estate if you're
right about London
look it's my favorites do you know what
do you understand that somebody once
bought this building for a dollar
somebody bought the land we're on for a
dollar once that happened it's a long
time ago
how do you know you're a practitioner
the reason I do is to how I learned you
got to put up all of you were like well
I can't do podcasting and Facebook and
Twitter oh but I can't I can block but I
can't why if you want it so bad my thing
is why if you want it so bad why can't
if you want to have a media company
around Caribbean food culture
why can't you I want to you know what I
want to see I want to see all your
minutes I want to see all your minutes I
want to give you d-roc for today I want
to watch you from the moment you wake up
to the moment you go to sleep let me
promise you something you're gonna get
exposed
so so that's why dailyvee happened
because you guys like a lot of you
didn't know me before daily be how many
people knew me before daily be well not
bad right
you got you got to really know me post
daily big you heard hard work and hustle
before you were confused and I've been
doing that [ __ ] everyday for 20 years
you and you and ten thousand other
people
d-roc how'd you get your job but he
offered me something like you have to
understand you know when people offer me
free videos today everybody big problem
I don't need it
that's right for all of us go ahead tell
him and timing right like listen I want
it for you like I didn't even know that
internship with me you saw I didn't know
that was off like I'm trying but I you
know you know you know me of you were
about to email me tomorrow I'm flying
from London to Austin Texas which is a
long flight and I'm gonna have a really
good chance of like actually getting to
it but if I don't even though I told you
take a photo and email me tonight you
got a real unlikely chance of getting
through the question is what do you do
next
do you try again some of you who knew me
11 times still no answers the person
next to you is gonna email me tomorrow
for the first time and get a full answer
it's just the game it's just the [ __ ]
game but who wants it smart to write I
know you want it bad I know a lot of
people want it bad
it's about being thoughtful of how you
know and I don't know
when you said she wants to go China I
always talk about like you know to your
point I'm glad you said that that was
cool
life is funny Tyler right learning so
much we're getting really close
literally was at the crossroads of a
terrible community manager at
vaynermedia
this is not a joke it's not a joke was
it the first day or what they were the
first day that Tyler was AJ AJ was
deciding between Tyler and Nick do whose
aunt like I loved and you may have seen
two to be his next assistant if Tyler
didn't get the job he would have left
cuz he was like [ __ ] this this is not
I'm not getting it the way I want life
is funny AJ on a flip of a coin I think
in his mind goes with Tyler right the
first day the Tyler is AJ's assistant
and isn't box we get an email from the
client the New York Jets our clients
which is amazing
the New York Jets and AJ an email now
Tyler sees all the email and says AJ
we'd love to talk to you we desperately
want Tyler Schmidt off the business yep
but yeah I want to keep telling the
story you have to understand if he
wasn't in consideration and AJ wasn't
ready for an admin if he didn't get the
admin job what would have happened was
at that moment we would have audited
what Tyler was up to Tyler was not in
the right headspace because he knew that
wasn't right for him when we audited
more than likely what it came back and
being like yeah he's really not that
good and he probably would've got fired
life is funny so the reason I'm telling
some of these stories is guys there's
there's a time when I'd like dönitz trip
to LA got cancelled maybe that was the
trip that I was gonna have the meeting
that was gonna change my life
i sat in San Francisco twice and passed
on uber an angel round right to my good
friends face had I said yes I would have
three to four hundred million dollars
more right now that's real life
like that should not I don't know what
to tell you that's just like that
happened in my life so I there's just so
many variables and this is why if you
listen I keep [ __ ] simple because you
think you're way more in control than
you are
you're in control when you make the
decision you're not in control after
that why do I make decisions so easily
because I know I'm never gonna know the
alternatives why do we pick London maybe
want to do London
we talk about other things like
everything is so much more chance than
you think which is why if you keep it
basic [ __ ] works out all of you were
just spending so much time overthinking
[ __ ] you have no [ __ ] control over
[Music]
are they are they working is it working
have you done them yet have you done the
ads have you done the ads your first
group of that okay but here hear me out
the fact that you're asking for what aus
works when you haven't felt the benefits
of the thing that's come out of my
[ __ ] mouth every day for hmmm the
thing you understand no but really like
it's like you're like I'm like there's a
great deal over here and you're saying
hey but is there even a better deal
somewhere yet that yep
it's not right it's it listen this is
and you know I'm never gonna waver it's
all about patience you've literally
let's just I want to drill this through
your [ __ ] head you literally are
curious about the other thing you
haven't even tasted the fruits of the
thing it's it's a bad indicator of
what's about to happen yeah but all of
you say [ __ ] to me and then I watch you
and you don't do it all um you're cool
with me when we're here together for
three seconds oh my god thank you get
patience I got you and then I go look
and then and then I go look at everybody
you know here's what I just so you guys
know what I do is now I learn because I
do the work I go and I'll tonight at one
o'clock in the morning or on the flight
we'll look at all the photos hashtags be
like that cool yeah I remember that kid
oh yeah that's a Caribbean dude you know
dude right and then and then I'll save
[ __ ] and then I'll you know you think
it's cool when I follow you and then I
go back and look and I will good do you
understand and like and like you've seen
hungry two minutes ago
so you see where I'm going you see where
I'm going guys what I sell for free by
the way is hard yeah man it's [ __ ]
hard like if it was so easy it's [ __ ]
hard
my home my country a car bike yes and
all I had was like videos and your
content
it's just pretty baby push forward good
for having nothing yeah for writing
lyrics I'm trying to go pull the chair
out of this [ __ ] and like write a half a
probably perfectionist so yes so badly
and you're also an artist yes and when
you're an artist you're in trouble yes
they're vulnerable
I never know where I read some lyrics I
write good music with the dregs it's
like I've had a trouble so perfectionist
I'm always correcting myself so I just
kind of ever like put all you you have
you have to put it out bro listen
there's tomorrow like there's tomorrow
like I don't know it's to say like this
is why I think you should document and
not create everybody's overthinking [ __ ]
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow like
you just have to understand that you're
wrong it's not even about if there's not
subjective put the [ __ ] song out like
whatever [ __ ] rhymed look tree this
time is good enough like I'm telling you
dog you know yes yes you're welcome
you're welcome so much I got you Mosca
yoga what's that okay yes yes went into
what yep yes right made you unhappy
neutral
yes yes yes yes okay that's a stupid
idea you don't need to license it
that's dumb lawyer talk in 2018 now you
can sell your time in your advice you
know you could also give it away because
if you give it away it may lead to the
next thing it all couldn't that how you
want to play it but if somebody isn't
business savvy right it's because
they're scared to ask for money I'll be
very honest with you I don't like asking
for money like I'm not a I'm not big
like I don't like it it's like you by
the way it's probably one of the reasons
you all like me so much I don't like
asking I'm really good at bringing value
so that it comes passively indirectly
but but you definitely aren't gonna
license what your what your friends mom
and I'm sure she's lovely doesn't
understand his ideas as IP in today's
internet world is not working out like
that's old school thinking pre-internet
like that I yeah I mean like like you
have a Brant you have a name for her
brand yeah I mean you could ask her for
500 bucks for a for a brand name and
maybe you pay somebody a hundred bucks
for the or five bucks on fiber for a
logo you see where I'm going you
sometimes need to add something to me
maybe you don't like how it feels to
have a name but you might like how it
feels to have a name and a logo cuz you
feel like you're giving her something a
logo
yeah I get it
why do you think everybody [ __ ] gives
us free music like it's exposure
alright Moscow yoga I know it's the last
one but I promise you you're welcome
good yes okay let's go let's go here we
[ __ ] go and really I'm really upset I
picked on him like [ __ ] I lost I [ __ ]
lost that was a tap out of all the
people pick this two three thank you so
much I love you
[Applause]
[Music]